[Musik]
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem hunger games level
games special
und zwar wieder mal mit ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz vielen youtube die sind
hier von crafter als ob das nicht das
pack of phoenix katja pustekuchen ecke
hannibal kälte orio baby putz in den
urlaubskoffer der flugplätze donegal der
ungespielt khd der dena den anc nicht
ins expert.de und flex kraft es geht
jeden momenten los und dann gibt sie
irgendein countdown oder irgendwie sowas
ich frage noch mal ganz kurz man geht ja
ok guck mal hält ok startet zwischen das
summer und denner ich werde nur die
erste runde mit auf den weg gibt eine
normale runde und eine team runde und
die team runde werde ich nicht mitmachen
weil ich gleich weg fahren muss zu einem
freund und davis und die normale runde
dies halt jetzt also die mache ich jetzt
ja so elterngeld turin spielt selber
auch mit weil wir nicht 16 leute
zusammen gekratzt haben alle schreiben
ratlos und weil sie billig sind
und das geht dann hier im moment los
hörl odina halbig geht hätte alle bereit
die hamann hunderttausend mal fragen so
dann macht gleich links an countern und
haben wir 10 sekunden und dann geht's
los ich weiß nicht ob ich nicht muss ich
weiß ich hab ich in mitte laufen sondern
oder da hinten ist auch seinen weg da
geht so hoch geht es da überhaupt hoch
ich weiß es nicht dass auf jeden fall zu
einer ecke er ist doch teil des parks
naja - 12 hey ich verstehe ich was kommt
los jedenfalls das geht im moment lebe
ich lasse dich mach jetzt auch keinen
stopp mehr weil das könnte jeden moment
losgehen
vielleicht dabei euro in 15 sekunden ok
ich weiß nicht ich glaube ich laufe
ersten die mitte holen irgendwas ist da
haben natürlich den vorteil die jetzt da
irgendwie stellen wir dir einfach direkt
darüber springen kann
obwohl eigentlich habe ich schon ganz
guten platz ich laufe einfach schon mal
solo sunny dann vielleicht bestimmte ins
wasser hundertprozentig völlig ins
wasser
[Musik]
mai in meiner kiste waren fisch und
zweierlei das war eine richtig gute
ausbeute
das war richtig richtig gut da habe ich
richtig gefreut dass ich dahin gelaufen
bin
das war richtig richtig dumme ja toll
noch mehr essen das ist ja jetzt richtig
cool hier und da hat er auch noch den
gleichen weg wie ich dumpfbacke weg los
ja ok läuft daher ich glaube hier her
sehr schön denke ich werde relativ
schnell sterben weil ich halt fast fast
gar keine sachen habe was ist sich jetzt
eben der kiste oder so man da ist ja
niemanden küsse ich hasste das ich habe
einfach nie glück barren ergänzt wie so
schnell weiter
[Musik]
haha das ist ein trick die kann man
doppelt gestern kann man von beiden
seiten öffnen oder auch nicht ich weiß
es nicht
neumanns taken falls einer kommt ein
steak ich den sind ja noch irgendwie
jetzt auch noch gästen heute sind die
weg das ist so dass sie nicht okay gut
jetzt ein bisschen ausrüsten so das ist
in die grace period vorbei
[Musik]
ich weiß es nicht ich muss hier erstmal
ein bisschen herum geschah ich brauche
auf jeden fall wie ein schwert oder so
wenn man schwert hat dann ist man schon
das so gut mit dabei war games ist das
immer so wenn ihr schwert hab dann nehmt
euch sofort das schwer wenn die kiste
voll mit essen und alle möglichen sachen
sind und beschwert dann holt euch die
gefahr dort
dreht die geräusche mal ein bisschen
runter das ist sehr sehr laut ist
allerdings ich werde sache herunter
gedreht haben wenn ich das dann ganze
dann ihr so bearbeitet und so weiß nicht
wen ich schwerter hier sicher noch gar
kein einziges wert gesehen
ich habe fressen überfressen aber noch
kein einziges tor schwert so jetzt noch
hier die kiste hier schaut euch das an
ein komplettes inventar wollen mit
fressen wollen was ist denn das für ein
kack und jetzt auch noch eine kiste ja
doch ein fall wo aber ich hab keinen
bogen
so ich habe auf jeden fall schon mal ein
schwert das heißt ich habe ein bisschen
respekt vor den leuten also ich hab
nicht respekt vor denen sondern die
müssen respekt vor mir haben will ich
habe er ein schwert hier geht es ganz
weit hoch jetzt nix
hier ist auch nix sehe ich irgendwelche
leute ich sehe auch keine leute okay gut
ist eigentlich schon ein gutes zeichen
wenn man keine leute sieht war ehrlich
bin übrigens froh und sehr fröhlich
gestimmt dass ich hier noch nicht wieder
aufgegangen bin oder so aber ich finde
eigentlich ist ein gutes zeichen wenn
ich keine leute sehe weil das heißt ja
dass die bei mir nicht in der nähe sind
es geht jetzt nicht darum höhe wäre
machte die meisten gilt sondern ist es
der hunger games wer überlegt lebt nicht
überlegt wer überlebt am längsten
aber die map ist auf jeden fall sehr
schön gestaltet war irgendwann gestern
war nicht kann ich nicht
[Musik]
ich habe einen bilderrahmen mit schwert
kaputt gemacht jetzt habe ich einst
legal oder soll ich das wieder aufhängen
ich glaube das ist nicht legal aber wenn
das so ist dann wäre es auf jeden fall
großer fehler
[Musik]
okay da vertraue ich war ich kann ich
schreibe ich euch einfach mal dass wir
das auch nicht macht so jetzt habe ich
auf jeden fall erstmal noch einen helm
und panzer und wir haben auf jeden fall
schon eine person getötet das hab ich
grad total runter laufen lassen hier in
meiner euphorie dass ich einen diamant
schwert gefunden habe was nicht ganz so
ideal
ja es war voll nicht legal dass das
gefundene mann nicht nur nicht so legal
das ist das gefunden habe aber ich habe
[Musik]
ein cia experte getötet und ich dachte
eigentlich der voll der profi aber der
hat noch keine sachen es war habe ich
mir dann zum vorteil gemacht
ich laufe einfach mal so ein bisschen an
den bergen her das ist wahrscheinlich
keine gute idee springen ist einfach
nicht ins wasser
kurz unter wasser bleiben oder noch ein
gutes wort komme ich hier überhaupt hoch
kann ich überhaupt wieder hochkommen
weiß es nicht ich bin eben ging es
erstmal gefangen
[Musik]
was mich hier raus hallo blau haye
ok dann gehe ich mal hierher einfach so
vielleicht ist sie ja irgendjemand /
vista wie viele leben noch ich weiß
nicht in der m50 noch leben weil das
wäre relativ cool endlich mal so dann
wäre ich top 5 boden der tatsachen
[Musik]
ich bin am boden der tatsachen das sehr
schön so hieß ihr das einfluss auch die
hannibal ist das tut mir leid ich kann
eigentlich die ganze zeit sprinten ich
habe so viel zu fressen
ich habe einfach nur fressen gefunden
der ersten zeit und ich weiß nicht ob
ich jetzt am dorf gefunden doch keiner
war weil die ganzen türen sind halt noch
hey hier war wirklich noch keiner dass
er cool wahrscheinlich eigentlich mehr
zu hey ich hab voll coole sachen und so
ja ich hab jetzt voll die chancen gegen
die ganzen anderen und soja und dann
realisiere ich dass die anderen noch
viel bessere chancen haben dann bin ich
total traurig genauso wie jetzt ablaufen
da ist auch nichts drin dieses da nichts
drin das heißt auch schon jemand das
wäre ihr vater glaube ich doch noch
keiner da ist einfach nur so nix drin
hast du in die kisten er ist nicht
[Musik]
irgendwie anders rein oder so ich möchte
muss noch mehr geben als und die paar
sachen hier ist noch so ein haus sobald
es übrigens ein neuer pc da ein paar
tagen wenn ihr das video seht ist er
vielleicht schon da nur ich denke solche
ganzen hey welche ganzen sachen werde
ich immer noch mit ohne shader aufnehmen
weil mit shader ist das alles hier so
ein bisschen die pace nicht wie soll ich
das beschreiben mit mit mit mit shader
ist das alles zwar cool aber es kann
sein dass man halt dass das ganze halt
ein bisschen hakt und ja ok skilled
rumgespielt mit woodstock das heißt sie
haben auch alle nur ein hotspot muss ich
gucken ob mein grußwort dann irgendwie
cooler ist oder so und das ist ja ein
ganz toller mann ist kann auch nicht
sein er ich finde die ganze zeit nur
essen
ich will mich ja gar nicht beschweren
aber es könnte auch eine vernünftige
schwerterin seiner indienreise und
schwert oder ok also schwer das jetzt
schon ein bisschen okay aber vielleicht
einen stein schwert oder irgend sowas ja
das wäre auch schon mal was
und halten nicht immer nur was zu
fressen ich bin es nicht nur die fans
der die ganze zeit fressen es in
minecraft so ist hier hängen was also es
gibt echt viele kisten das befürworte
ich ja auch mal findet fast bei jedem
haus eigentlich jetzt jetzt keine aber
problem ist halt die tatsache der inhalt
freiwillig ob da was geht so was ist
hier so ich könnte ja mal versuchen
einfach auf das schiff dazu kommen so
ist das fressen aber das ist aber schon
cool aus also die map an sich ist
richtig geil ich glaube dass es eben
eine map außen schaut play von cape to
rio de janeiro wird die nach mir was für
ein loser das ist 100 prozentig karte
das ist 1000 prozentig cartel der wir
jetzt zum teufel wird
es ist okay doch nicht sorry da wird der
sieg sei dieser lutscher wurzeln der
flieg bestimmt über mir und iss oder so
das sind in taiwan
[Musik]
gome gehweg hohoho la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la wir sind doch nicht
alle ich dachte jetzt alle will mehr ich
glaube dass ich einfach nur die sache
raus genommen die er brauchte darum
glaube ich karten namen gesehen wenn ich
jetzt ein stein schwer dich geh sofort
interessiert wir sind überall kisten
aber nirgendwo ist irgendwie was gutes
drin
ich finde 1000 kisten aber
nur ist jetzt gehts runter das ist doch
bestimmt irgendwas kommission brauche
ich sehe jetzt schon so viele kisten mit
inventar ist gleich voll und einfach nur
voll mit essen
guckt euch das an ich habe ein halbes
deck groß fleisch zieht euch mal an wie
viele kisten hier sind mann ich hatte
noch nie so viele kisten in der partie
man alter wie krass ist das denn ich
sage jetzt erst mal ein paar sachen die
ich nicht brauche so durch alle breu
nicht dass ein helm kann ich meine
einfach wegschmeißen und mit ihnen
aufsetzen
ach komm wenn jetzt nichts gibt was drin
ist dann nehme ich das auch nicht mit
ich nehme es doch mit nein dies weg nein
das ist doch doof dass man so ein
bisschen rum waren eisenrose drin und
eisen brustpanzer das ist gut
[Musik]
also brustpanzer ist wirklich sehr gut
kisten öffnen mit luca hey hey so
schauen wir das ist ein paradies für
jeden hunger games profi
[Musik]
ich höre eine leiter
das kann doch nicht sein älter da
wechsel ich da aussehen auf das falsche
schwerte
[Musik]
man da dachte ich schon so vollständig
und so grenze ok wahrscheinlich gilt der
mich jetzt nicht weil er gesehen hat
dass ich eigentlich ganz gute sachen
haben und sich gefragt hat warum ich
weggelaufen bin okay wir wissen wir sind
nicht allein
[Musik]
ich hätte als erst mal hoch
hu freunde das war anstrengend aber der
typ hat er nichts worauf ich mich mitten
auf mich geschlagen hat oder hatte okay
das ist einfach nur eine wolke hier drin
ok ich denke ich gehe wieder runter wo
könnte der denn sein ist wahrscheinlich
irgendwo hinten drin jetzt wer lebt noch
[Musik]
ist hier jemand irgendjemand möchte doch
nur spielen
doch nicht okay dass wird er
wahrscheinlich gewinnt
[Musik]
nein bei mir hakt so der aber dass es
richtig schrecklich es war gut okay ich
wurde fünfter
[Musik]
dann würde ich sagen was das für diese
folge 17 minuten aber ich habe lange
überlegt und ich habe länger überlegt
als ju place und die anderen die aber
noch sind dann würde ich einfach sagen
alle anderen kanäle sind in der
beschreibung wir sehen es beim nächsten
mal schießt euch gefallen hat könnt ihr
eine positive bewertung abgeben und wenn
die kommentare schreiben welche szene am
besten wandernd ist bis zum nächsten mal